[Music]
[Applause]
he's Nick Wright first things first
co-host Fox Sports One
great to see you Nick how's life
oh it'd have been better uh if I'd have
seen you what was it Tuesday Wednesday
night yeah does America know that you
got the single most prestigious award in
radio and you couldn't be deigned to
show up do they know well
I wanted to spend time with my wife
okay so here's the thing so Dan got a
Marconi I was at the awards not because
I was nominated I of course when I was a
radio professional was snubbed 15 years
in a row but because my dear friend
Danny Parkins was nominated for the
second most prestigious award in radio
and he lost to some dope from Boston I
couldn't believe it but that doesn't
matter I'm sure Greg Hill does a
mediocre job whatever Danny Parkin
should have won does a great job in
Chicago but I text Dan I was like Dan
you're nominated for broadcaster of the
Year excited to see you and he's like
I'm vacationing in somewhere I don't
know Santa Fe or something so I'm like
okay and then Dan sent me an odd text he
was like you can give my speech if I win
but then I was working the room and I
saw D.L Hughley there and I'm like DL
and I of course go way back so I was
talking about like deals nominated the
same category Dan's not gonna win so I
wasn't really prepared then they call
your name I'm like oh I gotta go give
this speech and I dance hand to God I
rushed the state and right before I got
there
some Dopey radio exec was like I'm here
to accept on Dan Patrick's behalf and
I'm like that's not what Dan would want
that is he'd want me to okay okay here
you go you can do your speech
he and the winner for the most
prestigious award in radio
is Dan Patrick
[Applause]
now to accept Nick Wright from Nick
Wright Fox Sports who from Fox Sports
and the what's right in the great
podcast which you can find on YouTube
and everywhere else listen Dan would
love to be here
um however
he was unable to make it due to a
previous family obligation he wanted me
to convey to you guys that he's honored
and touched by this
and he's a little miffed that his radio
bosses didn't even tell him about the
event or else maybe he'd have shown up
to it
however with that said I'm going to use
my remaining 30 seconds
uh to say what has really propelled Dan
into his Golden Years broadcasting is
his eye for young Talent such as myself
and that brings me to the end of the
speech and most notably Dan to a wrinkle
to this story that you did not know
because I have little birdies everywhere
and someone sent me yesterday
your Marconi submission
and you might not even know this but
here is it's 90 seconds long here is
what you submitted
Russell Wilson breaking news on your
show
Scottie Pippen breaking news on your
show and then or there was one
non-interview submission part of it do
you know what it was it was you calling
me Dick wrong that wasn't the Marconi
the kicker of your submission is you
saying you can find him on Twitter get
Nick right
that
that is true that was on my tape
that's that I know that you helped me
win a Marconi yeah so I know you just
sent me a watch a few months back I
expect another package and I expect that
package to be the Marconi okay I feel
like I want it as much as you did all
right dick wrong you can't go wrong with
dick wrong
going for back to back you want to talk
sports sorry I hijacked your show no
you're sometimes you look like Alan
Rickman
oh Alan Rickman George Carl that son of
a gun yesterday on Twitter who said I
look like Tom Green and then called me
kylo Ren who evidently Adrian Brody
plays him no don't you see a little bit
of Alan Rickman from Die Hard not the
villain from Die Hard yes okay sure yes
how about shoot the gloss
so you want to know the worst you looks
like that I get there's a french guy who
used to be a big time soccer player I
don't think he plays anymore his name is
Frank Ribery your listeners can Google
and maybe you guys Paulie Paulie news oh
yeah yeah yeah so I get that but here's
what's so devastating about that comp
Frank Ribery has God bless him I'm not
judging him a massive facial scar it's
like the defining thing about him and
people like you look just like that guy
I'm like I've got I might not be that
handsome but I don't I wasn't in a car
accident like what so you're the you're
the before that's the after see oh okay
that's good yeah that's good
um are you okay with this tuatanga
violoa situation
him playing been cleared
so here's what I find odd
it everyone to me
feigned outrage and by that I don't mean
people weren't really upset about what
we saw the second concussion that was
horrible the way it looked all of it
but
Kenny Pickett
is also cleared to play in this game
Kenny Pickett is just went through in
the previous game the exact thing tool
went through in the game against was it
the Saints the one not the scary scary
concussion but the game and we were all
like oh my God I can't believe they let
him play the next week and nobody cares
that Kenny Pickett's playing there was
my apologies for not knowing the name
there was a player this weekend
that on the first drive of the game
it looked like he might have got a
concussion he got checked out cleared
played 80 plays the rest of the game and
then Monday morning showed up on the
injury report in concussion protocol so
they missed it even though they said
we're not gonna miss it so it what it
does seem like the the long tail of the
Tua thing is we're gonna have a lot of
bad roughing the passer calls and not
necessarily a better concussion protocol
so I don't I don't love that I but to
answer your question directly am I okay
with tuatanga Viola
if the doctors have cleared him making
an adult decision and saying I want to
do this like do I believe he should have
that right I do but I think a lot of the
commentaries surrounding it has been a
little disingenuous okay
I saw where Travis Kelsey restructured
his contract and I guess at first glance
I mean this happens all the time but I
immediately thought with the trade
deadline
maybe with obj out there or I thought
maybe you know Christian McCaffrey like
any of these teams if you can make a
move to get somebody and you keep him
away from somebody else is there
anything to Travis Kelsey restructuring
his deal
or yeah
yeah no I think it's the that Chief said
it was because we could bring up a
practice squad player that with respect
to the Chiefs that's obvious nonsense
they already had three million in space
they cleared up three and a half more
million but I would here's a underrated
storyline of the Year okay not like a
major storyline but underrated fact the
number one scoring team in the league is
the Kansas City Chiefs the offense is
not the issue now what I like about a
right tackle sure but offensive lineman
don't get available at the trade
deadline nobody even bad teams like we
got to keep those yeah would I like them
to acquire another pass rusher I would
Robert Quinn who the bear Robert I don't
think Brian Burns is going to
necessarily be available if he is I
think he's too expensive but a few years
ago the Chiefs added Terrell Suggs and
he was awesome and the playoffs helped
him win a Super Bowl last year they
added Melvin Ingram he was excellent for
the team and now he's playing really
well in Miami so I do think there's
something there but I wouldn't have I to
me with the Panthers I'm sorry what the
Niners just did with McCaffrey it's if I
tell told you Dan I just bought a
Bentley and be like well that's exciting
like yeah it's used the previous owners
said it broke down a lot and I paid
double the sticker but I do have this
Bentley now like it's exciting but I
think the Niners paid a hefty price for
it I wouldn't have wanted the Chiefs to
make that move a second and third or
fourth and a fifth and you pay a running
back 12 million a year seems steep I get
why the Niners did it but if the Chiefs
are gonna do something they need to
upgrade the defense they need to get
another pass rusher I can't let you go
without talking about the Lakers
situation granted it's only two games
but Russ goes over 11. and he said he
played said he played solid yeah and he
played solid yeah over 11. is he trying
to get traded I'm I'm trying to figure
out what the end game is with him
so here's the thing if people didn't and
I don't blame him if they didn't it was
yes it was busy Sports saying that game
was on late
if you like Russ was working his [ __ ]
I will give Russ credit there were three
straight possessions where he was
one-on-one against Kauai and stole the
ball twice and once I think drew a foul
he was working hard so I don't think
he's tanking and like get me out of here
he's just broken as an offensive player
but here's the biggest frustration with
the Lakers and this is why Rob polinka I
understand that
Kurt and Linda Rambis and Phil Jackson
and one of the Bus kids thought it was a
good idea to get blinking extension but
we have seen proof of concept for two
decades in this league
that if you put shooting around LeBron
James you're going to win 50 some games
and be a contender now it's now two
straight years the Lakers have built a
roster as if threes aren't worth more
than twos and trading Russ won't fix
that it might help it some depending on
who you trade them for and I do
understand the idea of because of big
Vic because of the French kid I think
more teams are going to turn the ship in
the tank Direction earlier than usual so
maybe you can get a better deal than the
Pacers deal but I don't understand how
you build a team out and not emphasize
shooting when you have LeBron and I
don't understand why Anthony Davis
refuses to play like the guy he used to
play like in Above the Rim inside force
and instead he's a worse jump shooter
than Russ yeah he's in the worst jump
shooter in basketball for two years
keeps taking them the only way Russ I
think can stay on the floor and stay in
the good graces is on the defensive side
where he will show that he is willing to
play defense because he didn't play
defense for Frank Vogel and if if he
does that I he's also got to understand
this Nick have court awareness of the
reason why they're giving me open
jumpers is because I'm not any good
right but here's the thing the starting
back court was one for 16. the backup
point guard was over nine they the the
the Patrick Beverly every time they do a
broadcast it's so frustrating and I'm
sorry I know he's friend of the show you
know what I mean friends friends Hall of
Famer Reggie Miller however I gotta tell
you that
um Reggie is waxing poetic about the
impact Patrick Beverly has and then the
graphics team kind of did Reggie dirty
because they put Beverly's stat line up
and it's like one for five zero assist
two turnovers it's like oh man I hope
he's better be Joel Osteen out there
with the motivation because he's not
exactly helping on the offensive end of
the Court
are you in on the Clippers
well
oh listen
if they are healthy
they're the best team in the west
however
Kawhi Leonard
is an odd duck man
Taurus ACL
two seasons ago and when it happened it
was like it's a knee strain they didn't
even tell us and now he's on a serious
minutes restriction this late at this
point since how about this Dan
since remember when Zaza put his foot
underneath him when why was with the
Spurs yeah that was more than five
seasons ago
since then Kawhi Leonard has played 179
games that is 306th in the NBA there's
only 450 players so the idea that you're
just gonna assign Health to the Clippers
I thought John Wall looked awesome but
he's a health risk Kawhi is a bigger is
the single biggest health risk in the
league and so yes if healthy I love
their coach I love their depth uh but I
think the if healthy thing is a big if
yeah it feels like everybody's all in on
the Clippers as that's the team to beat
and I'm like I still like Golden State
still like them and the the youth
movement uh the depth they have there
you got the Draymond issue uh yeah but
they're I think they might trade
Draymond and and solve that issue and
add something significant I think
Draymond plus one of those kids
could get you something Dr you know what
I mean Draymond plus coming or Draymond
plus Moody you slide wise men into his
minutes because they made they paid
Wiggins they paid pool they're not
paying Draymond too and Draymond gave
them an out like there was gonna be a
like oh you've got to give him the
contract out of loyalty not when he's
slugging people
um but so yeah so I I think the Warriors
are not fully formed I'll tell you a
team that is fully formed and is fully
almost uh stuck is cooked is a team that
I have season tickets for the Brooklyn
Nets that team's a mess and it's not
gonna you know what they played like the
other night
like they wanted their coach fired and
riddle me that they actually demanded
the coach be fired prior to the season
like they're they're and Kyrie's out
here talking about winning MVP and
defensive player over the year like it's
just out of their mind
thanks again for helping me win the
Marconi
oh you know what it is it goes on my
resume now you know what I mean like a
Marconi contributor uh Dan I appreciate
you I appreciate your friendship uh and
I will uh see you soon for dinner that I
think is your turn to buy
no
didn't I get the lunch what do you mean
I thought I got the last one and yeah
the last one but I bought drinks at that
Marconi thing that I'm sorry you never
picked them up it counts all right okay
um all right my best to your wife as
always what
what is rude that was rude I said say
hello to your wife I've met your wife
it's called all the best you said all
the best and then you said as always
with a little Dan Patrick wink don't
appreciate that nothing gets past me sir
I'll talk to you next time see ya my
best to your wife oh
he's good talented gun